Ciao ragazze per realizzare il tutorial di oggi ho usato questi tre pennelli quindi procurateveli anche voi
No non è vero ,non è un tutorial, è un video sulle ragazze quando si truccano aspettativa e realtà perché
ho deciso di fare questo video perché tanti di noi sono molto brave a truccarsi tante altre non ci riescono e guardano tutorial su tutorial, ma comunque
insomma devono migliorare un pó
Ho deciso di fare un video per tutte e due queste categorie e l'ho diviso in sezioni, quindi a seconda della parte
del nostro viso che dobbiamo truccare
buona visione
♡Musica♡
ed è subito Bahamas!!!
Guarda un po' qua a forza di vedere tutorial ragazzi!
♡Musica♡
Dá un pó l'effetto occhiaia, però fa moda
Sì si!
Grazie o mio dio dedico questa vittoria a mia mamma e a tutta la mia famiglia
Grazie per avermi  sempre sostenuta e avermi comprato tutti questi trucchi, adoro!
Fare una riga lungo l'occhio e unire così
Però questo è più sottile
♡Musica♡
eye-liner e smokey eye in un colpo solo!
Sì pronto carissima, si mi stai disturbando perché sto facendo un video ci sentiamo dopo ciao ciao.
Ciao ragazze spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
volevo farvi vedere gli 800 dischetti di cotone che ho usato, mi sono truccata e struccata
700 volte, ho la faccia fucsia, ma spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
mi sono divertita molto a girarlo (no non è vero)
Si mi sono divertita moltissimo a girarlo,  bellissimo video e come al solito se vi è piaciuto mettete like,
iscrivetevi al canale e seguitemi su tutti gli altri social : instagram Facebook, Snapchat e Musical.ly
E comunque Top Adoro! Ciao
♡Musica♡